hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar pre-term
labor and rupture of membrane management
diagnosis and prevention in pregnancy i
am jennifer woods of lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by kyogen to learn
more visit
kyogen.com let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker tanya
nikolova
md msc phd department of gynecology
obstetrics and reproductive medicine
academic teaching hospital of the
university of heidelberg
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr nikolova you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for the nice
introduction
i'm tanya nicolowa from clinical
middlewarden in baden-baden i'm very
happy today to talk about the most
challenging
uh problem in our everyday practice
pre-term labor and rupture of membrane
management diagnosis and prevention
in pregnancy
today's agenda is a bit
for questions the first one which we
should answer today is what is the
current protocol for identifying
patients with threatened preterm labor
is there a change in
algorithm or patient care with the
ongoing pandemic
the second one what role do biomarkers
play and what is the difference
between them the third one how can a
better
diagnostic method impact management of
preterm labor
and rupture of membrane patients and the
last one
what role do biomarkers play in the
management of suspected
rupture of fatal membranes what are the
recommendations
amidst the pandemic
we will start with the first one and
we from our practice know that clinical
symptoms and biophysical methods are not
sufficient to make a treatment decision
because of their very low positive
predictive value
we know that the presence of clinical
symptoms does not necessarily
indicate an imminent delivery
here is presented a typical european
protocol for diagnosis of patients with
signs and symptoms of future
labor when a patient comes with one
symptom or many of them
the first thing which we do is a
transvaginal ultrasound
if the cervical length is less than 25
millimeters
the patient is admitted for 48 hours
if the contractions are active we begin
with tocolysis and corticosteroids for
fatal lung
maturations if no delivery occurs
patient is checked again after 48 hours
if the cervix is dynamic and there are
still regular contractions the patient
is kept
longer for observation if no delivery
occurs patient is checked again
after 48 hours if she is stable the
cervical length is not
shorter and the symptoms subside the
patient could be
is discharged if with trans vagina
ultrasound
the cervical length is detected to be
more than 25 millimeter
and there are no active contractions
nowadays the patient
is discharged if active contractions
patient is observed for 24
hours and examined again
who has issued guidance for management
of pregnant
women in covit 19 pandemic what we
should
talk to our patient which information
should be
shared with the patients are the
following
if you are infected with carbon 19 you
are still most likely to have no
symptoms or a mild illness from which
you will make a full recovery if you
develop more severe symptoms or your
recovery is delayed
this may be a sign that you are
developing a more
significant chest infection that
requires enhanced care
you should contact your maternity care
team immediately
there may be a need to reduce the number
of antenatal visits you have
however do not reduce your number of
visits without
agreeing first with your maternity
and here are shown the guidance for
obstetrical scare providers during
covent
19 pandemic if a woman meets criteria
for covet 19 testing she should be
tested
until test results are available she
should be treated
as though she has confirmed covet 19.
do not delay obstetric management in
order to test for covet 19.
elective procedures like induction of
labor for
indications that are not strictly
necessary routine growth scans
not for strict guidance based
indications
and routine investigations should be
reduced to minimum
at discretion of care provider
if ultrasound equipment is used it
should be decontaminated
after use
as obstetricians we have a very
important role in this corona time
on one side to reduce exposure of
pregnant women with telemedicine
on the other side to provide timely and
adequate care
uh for patients which present with signs
and symptoms of preterm labor
and freedom rupture of fatal membranes
we came to the second questions we
should answer now what role do
biomarkers play
and what is the difference between them
in prediction of pre-term delivery
what we know from the statistics is the
following
up to 30 percent of patients presented
with signs and symptoms of threat and
preterm labor
may be admitted to the hospital only 5
to 10 percent of these patients
go on to deliver within 7 days
this results in up to 85 of unnecessary
and avoidable admissions
tocolytic agents especially beta
mimetics have several known maternal
side effects
including increased risk of maternal
palpitations
nausea tremor choreoamnionitis
hyperleukemia and hippocalymia
multiple rounds of corticosteroid
administration are not recommended
due to their association with adverse
neonatal site effects
including lower birth weight head
circumference
and shorter height so a very
important question stands in front of
all of us obstetricians
and it is can we more accurately assess
patients with signs and symptoms of
greater
labor the timing of antenatal
corticosteroids is also very
important there are many published
literature which
say that optimizing the timing of
antenatal corticosteroids can improve
outcomes for newborns but on the other
side
40 percent increase in mortality is seen
in
infants given antenatal corticosteroids
more than seven days before birth
compared with an interval of one to
seven days
the risk of infant mortality is doubled
with shorter or longer administration to
birth intervals of antenatal
corticosteroids
and birth than one to seven days
statistically significant increase in
risk of intubation is seen in neonates
born at 8 to 14 days of antenatal
corticosteroid administration
compared with intervals of 1 to 7 days
higher odds of mortality and necrotizing
enterocolitis
is associated with administration of
antenatal corticosteroids
when given more than seven days before
birth
we have performed a prospective
observational study which was
multicentric study
and uh was uh around
three uh lasted for three years
um in this uh from this studies which
what we get from our statistics
is that current protocol when looking at
cervical length for less than 25
millimeters
captures about 31 percent of patients
which will deliver in the next
seven days after testing patients with a
cervical length
from 25 to 30 millimeters have a 17
risk of delivering within seven days but
we currently do not observe them due to
limited
resources approximately 60
of patients fall in an equivocal
cervical
length range with cervical cervix for
15 to 30 millimeters long in
which the risk assessment for preterm
birth is not
conclusive
on this slide i have presented
our 203 investigated patients
and they are stratified according to the
cervical length
in cervix 10 to 15 millimeter long 15 to
20 millimeter long
20 to 25 25 to 30 millimeters
30 to 35 and more than 35 millimeters
there is a curve and above this curve
there are
numbers in percentage which show how
many of the patients
in this group have delivered in the next
seven days
uh patients with shorter cervix uh 100
percent of them delivered
all of them patients with cervical
length 15 to 20 milliliter
millimeters 55 of them delivered 20 to
25 percent
21 of them delivered
and these are the patients which are
actually
um in the current protocol patients with
less than 25 millimeters
not the others what we have found out in
our study
as a huge problem was the group of
patients with cervical length from 25 to
30 millimeter
uh they were 29 of our recruited
population and they delivered uh 17
of this group delivered in the next
seven days
uh then we ask ourselves if biomarkers
can
optimize identification of patients at
risk of delivery within seven days of
assessment
in order not to miss this 17 percent of
patients with cervical length more than
25 millimeters
today at the market there are uh three
biomarkers
uh available which are used for the
prediction of glitter and delivery
fatal fibronectin is a glue-like protein
that holds the developing
baby in the lump phosphorylated insulin
like growth factor binding protein
1 is found in high concentration in the
horiod residual interface
placental alpha microglobulin 1 pmg 1
is the placental protein that is
released into the amniotic
cavity as a result the release of fatal
fibronectin and phosphorylated
insulin-like growth factor bending
protein 1 into the vaginal cavity
can be caused by digital examination or
manipulation of the cervix
because png-1 is not known to be found
in the extracellular matrix
it may not be as easily released due to
such
manipulation
the part of sure test is the
market name of pmg-1 and this protein
which is found in very high
concentration in amniotic fluid 2000 to
25
000 nanogram per milliliter and it could
be also found in very low concentration
in normal vaginal discharge
recent clinical studies have
demonstrated a strong correlation
between a positive png-1 test and
imminent delivery
in patients presenting with threatened
preterm labor and intact
membranes a publication from 2012 from
lee and romero
postulated two possible explanations for
the presence of png-1
in cases of threatened preterm labor
the first postulation as the
transformation of png-1
through choreoamniotic pores in fetal
membranes
could occur during uterine contractions
and the second one if the degradation of
extracellular matrix or fetal membranes
could occur due to inflammatory process
of
labor and or infection
there are many studies which are
performed in the last
10 years all over the world across
different
nationalities of patients i have
presented here the most important
and i have divided them in three groups
a low risk group with number of events
number of preterm deliveries
um in the next seven days of less
or equal to five percent or cervical
length more than
three percent a three centimeter then
the second group is the group with
intermediate risk for preterm delivery
where the number of events was five to
fifteen percent the cervical length one
point five to three centimeters
and the last two are presented by
high-risk population
with more or equal to five 15 percent of
uh
preterm delivery and cervical length of
less than
1.5 centimeter we could see
that in all populations uh you know in
the whole population the negative
predictive value is very high it's
higher than
uh 94 but the positive predictive value
in
intermediate risk group and high-risk
group is also very high
high from 50 to
100 percent
here is presented a comparative anal
analysis between
uh two biomarkers biochemical markers
pmg one and fatal
fibronectin in biophysical marker
cervical
land in a population of 2000 2003
patient prospective observational study
we have examined the prediction
power of these biomarkers in the next
seven days after recruitment we have
found of
a very high negative predictive value
for all
three investigative biomarkers but the
png
one appeared to have significantly
higher positive predictive value of
76 which was uh much higher than the one
of fatal fibronectin and cervical length
when the cut off as a cutoff was
taken 25 millimeters
this is another population of 328
patients
where we have compared the png-1
versus phosphorylated insulin like
growth factor building protein 1
versus cervical length and again
the negative predictive value was high
for all the investigated biomarkers
but the positive predictive value of pmg
1 was remarkable 60
um for pmg one
the publication uh from 2017
from ravi and collaborators have done a
comparison
between pmg one which was qualitatively
assessed versus quantitative fatal
fibronectin
and they have done this comparison with
two different cutoffs for fetal
fibronectin
50 nanograms per milliliter and also
200 nanograms per milliliter and compare
the
uh predictive power of
these three parameters
but again part of sure or png-1
had significantly higher positive
predictive
value
i have presented here the systematic
review
and meta analysis uh published by
melchor
and collaborators and this meta analysis
shows that ppv for pmg one is
higher than the one of fetal fibronectin
and phosphorylated insulin
ly growth factor bringing protein one
within seven days of
testing the most of the population was
with high risk a number of events
uh more than 15 percent and very short
cervical length less than
1.5 centimeter they have concluded
that the use of a highly specific assay
like part of sure
in threatened preterm labor may optimize
the management of these
patients
uh in this systematic uh review it also
reported the area under the curve
for all tested biochemicals biomarkers
and pmg one appeared with highest area
under the curve
from 0.961
area under the curve is a measure of how
well a parameter can distinguish between
two
diagnostic groups diseased and normal
so pmg one captured the diseased patient
very well very powerful
for a better understanding for better
perception i have
presented the results of this
meta-analysis in a table
as well and we could see that the
positive
predictive value of pmg 1 was 76
negative predictive value 97 positively
likelihood ratio very high 22.51
negative likelihood ratio law
zero point 24
area under the curve as mentioned knew
0.961
and the positivity rate of pmg-1 was
significantly
lower than one of the fatal fibronectin
and phosphorylated
insulin-like growth factor binding
protein 1
which means that pmg 1 gave a very low
number of false positive results
piriani and collaborator uh
in 2019 also published a meta-analysis
and they found out they showed that the
positive
likelihood ratio and negative likelihood
ratio
are consistent for risk assessment
within published
data
so which biomarker is most useful
based on the publications comparing pmg
1 with fatal fibronectin and
phosphorylated
insulin like growth factor binding
protein 1
pmg 1 seems to be a useful biomarker for
prediction of spontaneous delivery
within seven days of testing
the guidelines for the management of
spontaneous preterm labor prepared by
the european association of perinatal
medicine
and published in the journal of maternal
fatal and neonatal medicine
in 2017 have incorporated
pmg 1 in
diagnosis of patients with signs and
symptoms of preterm
uh delivery their main points are the
following
bearing in mind the negative predictive
value of such tests
part of sure png-1 fatal fibronectin
is negative and cervical length by
ultrasound
is more than 2.5 centimeter we recommend
that tocolytic therapy and steroid
prophylaxis should be withheld
bearing in mind the positive predictive
value of part of sure
we recommend that tocolytic therapy and
steroid prophylaxis should be
administrated
with such management there are benefits
to the hospital and benefits to the
patient
benefit to the hospital reduces
unnecessary admissions
and transfer to neonatal intensive care
unit
cost savings to the hospital reduction
in
administering medical management and
availability of that
benefits to the patients unnecessary
medical intervention
peace of mind uninterrupted travel plans
employment less burden on spouse and
family
we steadily come to the third question
what should we answer next
is how can a better diagnostic method
impact
management of preterm labor and rupture
of membrane
patients
here is shown a protocol where pmg
one could guide the pre-term labor
admissions
this protocol is in white's use in spin
and united
arab emirates so when a patient presents
with signs and symptoms of christian
labor
what is first done is collecting png-1
from vaginal sample uh then they do
digital exam then they do transvaginal
ultrasound for cervical land
management and they do cardiotography
if they have dynamics uterus and they
have
cervical changes and these cervical
changes
are sufficient they admit the patient
and they treat the patient with
tocolytics
and corticosteroids if there are no
cervical changes they guide they
yourself
according to the part of a test with
negative tests they discharge the
patient
with positive tests they keep the
patient and they observe the patient
if the cervical changes are insufficient
then cervical length is the one who will
decide
how the patient will be managed
further with cervical length of more
than 25 millimeters
in gestational uh age groups 24 to 31
week
weeks and more than 15 millimeters
uh in 32 to 34 weeks the patient could
be freely discharged
if the cervical length is less than 25
millimeters
and less than 15 millimeters in already
mentioned
gestational age weeks
again the guidance is according to the
biomarker
test result with positive biomarker
tests the patient
will be treated uh or are treated
with negative tests the patient are kept
for observation
and um estimation of the situation
uh later
here it presented a combined pmg-1 and
cervical length protocol to guide
preterm labor admissions
and this protocol is used in
most of the european countries
nowadays who could afford in their
settings the png-1 biochemical markers
it goes uh in this way when patient
presents with times and symptoms of free
term labor
the patient gets diagnosed with
transvaginal ultrasound
and cervical length is being determined
when the cervix is shorter than 15
millimeters
the patient is admitted therapy is
administrated
if the cervical length is more than 30
millimeters
and there are contractions more than for
in 20 minutes
the patient is observed for additional
two hours
if no cervical changes she will be
discharged
if the cervical cervix is long
more than 30 millimeters and there are
no significant constructions the patient
is discharged immediately
the most problematic group is the group
with cervical and 15 to 30 millimeters
where pmg one helps
much we use this marker in our settings
on
daily basis so if we get this positive
pmg one in this group
we test we admit the patient we
administer therapy
if the test is negative then the patient
gets discharged
um here is presented study
uh publication of volotsky and
collaborated from 20 and 18.
they have compared png
1 tested alongside with cervical
land and cervical length test it alone
and they have assessed the predictive
power of these two modalities
part of sure proof cervical length when
cut off is 25 millimeter and cervical
length alone
when when with the same cut of 25
millimeter
what they found is um a
high negative predictive value but
um 10 times higher positive predictive
value
when part of sure is used uh together
with cervical uh land in the group of
patients
uh which have cervical and 15 to 30
millimeters so the predictive power is
uh
pretty higher when we do use the these
two modalities together
the cost of reducing false results false
positives can result in unnecessary
medications
transfers hospital admissions and
induction
a false negative result on the other
side can lead to an
unwarranted discharge which could cause
lifelong complications and patient
litigation
hero is presented visually the reduction
in unnecessary admissions
when the patient are tested with pmg-1
versus fatal fibronectin
these are the results from our study so
we have found out that for
every 100 women presented with signs and
symptoms of three term labor
parato sure produced 18 positives of
them
four were false positive fatal
fibronectin produced
32 positives of them 23 were
false positive
avoiding unnecessary treatment causing
maternal and neonatal side effects
when um presumed diagnosis of free term
labor has been made stockholies
commenced to delay labor those allowing
time for the administration
of a full course of corticosteroids
current benefit and risk data are
insufficient to support routine use of
repeat or rescue courses of fundamental
corticosteroids in clinical practice
in women who remain at increased risk of
preterm birth
after receiving an initial course of
antinatal corticosteroids
multiple courses are not recommended
avoiding unnecessary treatments reduces
maternal and neonatal side effects
pmg-1 has shown to be useful to guide
patient therapy
the use of tocolytic agents should be
individualized
and based on maternal condition
potential side effects and gestational
age according to habershagen the high
rate of unnecessary use of tocolytics
suggests a significant opportunity for
patient safety
improvements via the combinatory use of
png-1 test and cervical length
measurement
and according to one housebaker based on
a positive png-1 test
in addition to cervical length
measurement unnecessary admissions
and drug administration may be reduced
by up to 71 percent
we came now to the third
question today how can a better
diagnostic method
impact management of preterm labor and
rupture of membrane patients
according to the german company based on
drg
and average cost of german calculation
hospitals
it's uh found out that every day a
hospital stay of a preterm labor patient
can be shortened
results into an up to 360
euro higher profit for the hospital
and according to fat colleen and his uh
publication in journal of mathematical
medicine
a negative part to sure test may be
useful to identifying patients that can
be safely discharged
after 24 hours of observation reducing
their
length of stay and burden on the
hospital
resources
in the summary soivag cervical land
measurement
is most useful to identify patients for
admission
and treatment when combined with a
biomarker test between
15 and 30 millimeters pmg one test
has the unique advantage of a very high
positive predictive value
with a high negative predictive value
leading to new options to improve
patient management in multiple clinical
situations
and better identification of patients
who are at high risk of delivery within
seven days
will avoid unnecessary admissions
unnecessary treatments and
transfers
what are the recommendation amidst the
pandemic
latest consideration for labor and
delivery from the society for maternal
federal medicine and the society of for
obstetrics and anesthesia and
perinatology
advice prolonged exposure to hide those
steroids
has been associated with worsening of
stars coronavirus patient outcomes
in the general population how this
applies to antenatal corticosteroid is
still
unknown until evidence is available
practices could consider adjusting
protocols
balancing theoretical maternal risk
against the magnitude of
known fatal benefits in each clinical
circumstances
and the last question what role do
biomarkers play
in management of suspected rupture of
fatal membranes
what are the recommendations amidst the
pandemic
uh already i have already mentioned in
pmg
one uh could be found in uh healthy
uh women during the whole pregnancy
the concentration is a very low 0.05
to 0.2 nanograms per milliliter
with a threshold of uh one nanogram per
milliliter it's an
indication for preterm labor with a
higher threshold of five nanograms per
milliliter
is indication for rupture of membranes
uh and in amniotic fluid pmg one is uh
present in uh very high concentration
two thousand to twenty five thousand
nanogram per milliliter
on the other side insulin why growth
factor building protein one is
ubiquitous protein also found in blood
and cervical vagina secretions
uh and phosphorylated insulin like
growth factor building protein one
has multiple isoforms accumulated in the
cells of
the sidua and could make an interference
with the accuracy
with their accuracy
this is the algorithm for rupture for
patients which
come with symptoms and or science
subjective of preterm
uh rupture of membranes we
initially should decide if really the
membranes are ruptured or not if they're
ruptured then
and there are contra indications to
expectant management we should deliver
the patient promptly if no contra
indications to expectant management we
should simply wait
and then our further management depends
on gestational
age in patients which are
less than 32 weeks pregnant or 32 to 34
weeks uh pregnant corticosteroids
antibiotics pstocholytics are mandatory
uh fetal surveillance is also very
important
we could offer elective delivery at or
after
32 weeks of gestation it's easier with
patients which are
more than 34 weeks pregnant we could
overhear
elective delivery without
any problem
here all presented traditional methods
which
are widespread first line use
and biomarker tests which are more
accurate
and easier to use to rule out
ruptured membranes nitrogen
ferning pulling are still in use but
they require a speculum insertion they
and many substances could interfere here
ultrasound could be also done but it can
only detect low levels of fluids
and it requires expertise and time
then the these methods could be used in
combinations
again these combinations are complicated
and they still do not achieve the uh
[Music]
needed specificity and sensitivity
amniotic infusion is
meant as a gold standard for a rupture
of membrane
diagnosis but it's a highly invasive
procedure it's expensive requires
expertise
and time at the moment on the market
there are four uh biomarkers
uh for the diagnosis of uh membrane
ruptures these are
quick check phetofibronectin which
detect the fat of fibronectin
glycoprotein
omni sure rupture of membrane taste
which detects
pmg-1 glycoprotein rupture of membrane
plus test
which detects both alpha phetoprotein
and
insulin-like growth factor binding
protein one
an actin prone which detects
insulin-like growth factor bending
protein
one alone um of
uh i analyzed all of them i'm sure had
the highest specificity
of 100 percent and very high sensitivity
of
almost 99 it is intended for detecting
leakage
leaking amniotic fluid and it's not
affected by
semen by blood and vaginal infections
what was the recommendation amidst the
pandemic latest consideration from
labor and delivery from the smfm and
soap
recommend alternative methodologies for
evaluation of rupture of membranes
could be considered given the potential
exposure
risk microscopy and ferning evaluation
for women with cells coronavirus or
patients
under investigation
i have presented here
i will present here three the most
relevant uh
studies in the field of membrane rupture
diagnosis the first one is a study for
published by sawsan collaborators which
have
evaluated the potential of png-1 test to
diagnose rupture of membranes by
comparing its performance
with the intra-amniotic insulation of
indigo carbon
in patients with ruptured membranes and
the statistic metrics is given
uh below so the sensitivity of pmg one
was 100 specificity 99
ppv 96.3 npv
100 percent
it means that omnishur is a pretty
potent biochemical marker to
rule in or rule out amniotic
membrane rupture
then ramzawar has performed a meta
analysis
and compared the diagnostic performance
of an immunoassay
for pmg-1 in vaginal fluid
with the insulin-like growth factor
binding protein 1
in the rupture of fatal membranes across
different
patient populations what they found out
is throughout all patient populations
known
and unknown membrane status the pmg-1
test has shown a significantly superior
performers
in all metrics than insulin white growth
factor binding protein test
they got sensitivity of 96 and
specificity of nine or almost 99
the same author has performed a
multi-site
prospective observational study and
evaluated the performance of tests
detecting placental
alpha-1 microglobulin and insulin-like
growth factor binding protein 1
and they evaluated it in the population
of pregnant women with vaginal bleeding
as well
what they found is that pmg-1 test
was significantly less affected by blood
admixtures than the insulin-like growth
factor building protein
one 11 of insulin-like growth factor
building protein one test but only two
percent of pmg-1 tests
were invalid due to blood
performance metrics for both of the
tests are given
in the table below and it could be seen
that there is a statistically
significant difference between
the both of the tests
and the last slide png-1 versus
insulin-like growth factor building
protein 1 versus alpha phetoprotein
insulin-like growth factor building
protein 1
in reduction in unnecessary admissions
it was found out that for every 100
women presented with suspicious
of pre-labor rupture of membranes
amnesia produced one false positive
actin brom produced 22 false positives
and rom plus
produced 25 false positive results
thank you very much for your attention
and i will be happy if i could answer
any of your questions today
thank you dr nikolova for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
our first question is
with the ongoing pandemic what is the
risk for the mother or the unborn
with the standard therapeutic management
you would usually administer
actual it's a great question precise
diagnostic is very important in this
situation
we should be pretty much sure who is
going to deliver in the next seven days
and who is going to
not to deliver corticosteroids and
tocolytics for
48 hours are mandatory in all cases
which are less than 34
weeks of gestation we should avoid
as much as possible a second shot of
corticosteroids
and as already reported a prolonged
exposition to corticosteroids
is unfavorable for the general
population in this corona period
we still do not know the influence of
prolonged corticosteroid therapy
on the sick corona mother and on her
unborn baby
okay thank you dr nikolova our second
question is
how can the use of biomarkers help in
the pre-term labor management during
pandemic where hospital admissions are
under pressure
um actually they could
do much because using the
biochemical marker markers we could
decrease emission rates by most accurate
diagnostic method
quick turnout time turnaround time
if they are easy to use the confidence
in this result is
pretty high these biomarkers
could be this biomarker testing
could be performed by residents by
nurses midwives
the time to obtain the results is very
short we don't
need to insert a speculum
uh and yes we we save
resources we save bets which is very
important in this corona time
patient bets
thank you so much dr nicolova our next
question here is
when is the best gestational age to give
beta methazone
and when should we not give it
a betamethasone is given everywhere we
should give everywhere
uh when the detection of h is less than
34
plus no gestational a week we should
avoid to give it
later we should avoid to give it the
second shot or to
reduce minimum when the
pregnancy is when
when we have a patient which is let's
say 29
weeks of gestation it's reasonable that
we will maybe
repeat it but we should minimize it and
the biomarkers
could help us uh very much in this
triage so we could be pretty much sure
if this patient will deliver or not in
the next seven days
okay we've got another question here
is it any useful of elastography of
cervix during transvaginal cervical
measuring
i don't know that i worded that
correctly oh
in everyday work i must admit we don't
use elastography
that much the published data
say that cervical length measurement is
more reliable and then cervical length
measurement together with biomarkers
could obtain pretty high
predictive values so i don't think that
we
need to do a lithography during
transvaginal
cervical measuring just to find out
if the patient will deliver or not
thank you dr nikolova we have a few more
questions the
next question here can the biomarkers
amnester
and pardo sure be used after vaginal
examination
well according to package instruction
package insert
they should be unused after 24 hours
after vaginal manipulation but studies
have shown that
part of sure can be used 30 minutes
after transvaginal ultrasound
and right after digital examination with
a very high accuracy of
95 percent
okay now our next question what is the
turnaround time of pamg1 test
it's uh five minutes the test could be
done in five minutes
uh 30 seconds um the swap
should be rotated in the vaginal cavity
around 30 seconds then additional 30
seconds rotation
in the vial and then we wait for
additional five minutes so in five
minutes we could
have a ready result um the pmg one
is very powerful to predict the delivery
in the next seven days
but also in the next 14 days we have
analyzed
it its performance metrics in the
14 days and we have found a slightly
slightly worse results than for seven
days
so we could be pretty sure that the
patient will deliver and or will not be
here even in the next 14 days
okay looks like we have one more
question here
how is the distinction done between the
membrane rupture
and risk of preterm delivery
actually the patient uh if the membranes
are ruptured we should clinically
tightly
monitor this patient um we should follow
the inflammation parameters ctg
should be done more tightly
the patient is at high risk to develop
choreoamnionitis the risk of treating
delivery is very high
if the pregnant woman woman is
more than 34 weeks pregnant she could
deliver
without high problems or huge problems
but
if there is pregnancy with the pregnancy
is less than
34 weeks or maybe less than uh
32 weeks the risk is very high
it's very challenging to manage such a
patient is
very challenging thank you dr nikolova
we
we do have a new question that just came
in um
pamg1 is a biomarker for both part of
sure
and amnester why don't we use
um only one test for either preterm
labor
or or rom
because png-1 in form of part of sure
detects a lower concentration of
placental alpha-1 microglobulin one
i have already mentioned its uh this
threshold
is one nanogram per milliliter when it's
uh more than one nanogram uh even when
it's even
five nanogram per milliliter it's a
highly suggestive
for rupture of membranes so they detect
the same
substance but in different concentration
part of sure could detect lower
concentrations
and i'm usually detect a higher
concentration
this is the difference and i have
already mentioned
how this pmg one came in the vagina
uh it's in the um
so it's a big quant it's a present in
the amniotic fluid
in a huge quantity and then it will be
saturnated it will be um
it comes in the vagina with
uterine contractions
thank you again dr tanya nikolova for
your time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor kia jin for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and both submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you very much